thank you james
right um i will apologize before i start
because i have had
issues with my chromebook i did it on
monday and it tried it on again
it only takes a minute to come back on
again um anyway um
good afternoon members welcome to this
planning meeting on the
14th of april 2021
um as usual i will read out first of all
um your names
and please confirm that you are
on this call no alphabetical order
um keith common cook here chair
thank you council robin you're here
chair
uh councillor joe payfoot here chad
councillor curry here chair
councillor john dennis our
dennis has just rung me this second and
said he can't get through
on his chromebook can uh democratic
services give him a ring or something to
help him
okay thank you for that sir uh
councillor pat moore
here chair uh nice to see you back pats
um thank you councilman garner
yeah i'm here chair thank you councillor
david hart
announcer heather keane
councillor paul moore here chair
uh councillor matthew scott where he's
not here but as you know i go through
the names
uh councillor zesky yeah present chair
uh council linda wright yeah chair and
obviously
myself um okay uh
the usual if i made members we have to
go through
my script um this afternoon if you have
any technical difficulties during the
meeting
then please contact democratic services
on call who will attempt to assist you
today
on call is katie her number is 507.046
and will be placed as she has done
already
in the chat box on the right of your
screen
i would ask all participants to mute
your microphone when you're
speaking this might minimizes the
background noise and will help everyone
in listening to the proceedings
microphones must only be turned on if
the participant has been granted
permission to speak
to gain by permission to speak please
make a note again
in the chat box on your right
if i do miss you please shout at me
members
and if you could wait and make a note
until the the other person has finished
speaking
with everybody prison please ensure the
mobile phones are turned to
silent and they are not used to make or
receive phone calls while this meet is
in in progress
please also refrain from checking emails
or conducting any other business
and ensure that you are in a quiet room
free from distractions
for the duration of this meeting
as you are aware members this meeting is
being live streamed
for members of the public and following
the meeting
the recording will be available on the
council's
youtube channel
at this point members i am going to ask
you
if you would as we are well aware now
that on friday of last week we all heard
the very sad loss of the duke of
edinburgh
um at the age of 99 um
so i would ask you to bear with me just
for a minute's
silence in his memory
and our thoughts obviously with the
queen and the members
of her family
uh thank you members
right moving on with our agenda members
requesting to speak under council
procedure
20.1 i have encounter brenda rogers
wishes to speak under item 4e 51
london road ramsgate uh councillor
pew on a gender item for
f land on the west side of tottenham
street
minster are there any other members
online who wish to um
speak please say so now
so we can make a note
okay there isn't thank you very much um
so agenda item one
apologies for absence i have received
apologies from
councillor scott i don't think there is
a substitute
for councillor scott
uh chair i've just managed to get on i
had trouble this is councillor dennis
yes i've just got on okay i'm here
thank you very much for the dentist yep
i see you pop up on my screen
thank you for that and you had a few
difficulties there thank you and
that is noted thank you thank you
so there's no other apologies for
absence
any declarations of interest
no agenda item three approving minutes
do members agree that the minutes of the
planning committee meeting which was
held
on the 17th of march 2021
be approved could i have a proposal
please
i propose that be checked councillor
chesky
i'll second it chair councillor alban
thank you very much the members agree
great agree
any member not agree no
they are carried thank you very much
agenda
item four uh schedule of planning
applications and public speaking
once again uh i think we're moving there
will be well but site visits will take
place
once it is safe to do so i think there's
a light at the end of the tunnel
hopefully for all of us there if uh if
we require site visits
the following items have been reserved
for public speaking
they are agenda items 4a
4c 4e
and 4f so if members could make a note
of that please
and now moving on for a point of
information i'm going to hand over to
our planning manager
um mr livingston
thank you chairman um the
i've got three points of information on
three of the agenda items
scheduled items are being discussed so
the first is on schedule item 4a
which is three viking close condition
six as proposed in the
agenda um recommends that
one of the windows is obscure glazed on
the first
floor side elevation um officers are
updating that condition
in terms of submitting the
recommendation to members
to require that all of the first floor
side windows on the north elevation
are to be obscure glazed and i'll
outline
which windows i'm talking about when we
get to the presentation on that item
uh on schedule item 4e
51 london road after the publishing of
the agenda the council received
six additional letters of support
meaning in total the council's received
22
letters of support on that planning
application
on schedule item 4f which is the land at
totsail street
condition 16 on the application outlines
the requirement for a scheme of
interpretation of archaeology on the
site so
uh requirements submit scheme including
potentially public art notice boards
to further the understanding of the
existing archaeology
um it's proposed to alter the stated
trigger
for the submission of those details as
currently drafted in the conditions in
the
in the council agenda uh from being
prior to the commencement of development
to actually prior to the occupation of
the development
and that is a change that has put
forward to members
in the recommendation by officers as
well
thank you thank you
moving on again to agenda item 4a
number three viking close uh i will ask
suki our legal officer
to read out the statement please
thank you chair this is a statement from
mr smith who i believe is the agent
this application seeks permission for
the redevelopment of the site
replacing an existing dilapidated
bungalow out of keeping with the area
to provide a three-bedroom detached
dwelling with private external amenity
parking and landscaping this process
driven high quality modern design
provides a positive addition to viking
close whilst
still respecting the surrounding built
form the building's appearance has been
developed to ensure that it sits well
within the surroundings
the area benefits from a mix of
architecture there is no
overriding style present the proposal
using modern materials and constructions
is in keeping with the gradual
architectural progression of the area
and more recently the modern
architecture behind the site on minis
road
the application site sits lower than the
adjacent park
and the larger dwellings behind on minis
road the neighbor opposite
the green walkway is significantly
larger than the existing and proposed
scheme
the proposed dwelling creates a
transition in height across the street
scenes
that will be in keeping with the
neighboring buildings and sit
comfortably within the larger built
context
the proposed scheme positively defines
the edge of the park
whilst maintaining privacy to the site
and all neighbours
a flat roof configuration is utilized to
minimize building mass
on the urban environment removing any
issues with loss of light or
overshadowing
first floor windows to the northern
boundary will be obscured following the
case office's recommendations
to remove overlooking to the nearest
building
the material pallet respects the area
and has been taken from buildings
close by with their use of brick and
render
this combination is of a common theme
with varying colors of brick
and render widely used green roofs are
proposed
on all the single-story flat roofs
parking is accommodated for on-site in
front of the attached garage
with cycle storage incorporated inside
the garage
the front garden facing the park will
incorporate a mixture of native
planting providing a low level buffer
zone
between the public and private spaces
the council raised that a tree with a
tpo
has been removed on the site the tree
was removed
years before by a previous owner and
this was
raised by the applicant prior to this
application being made
ongoing discussions concluded the need
for the
replanting of a sycamore tree this has
been agreed and included in the
landscaping scheme
this application has had nine letters of
support from neighbors
highlighting the delight at this current
eyesore site being tidied up and
redeveloped
the proposal has encouraged the other
building owners of viking close to
update and smarten their existing
buildings and frontages
passing walkers have expressed their
pleasure and delight upon seeing the
huge improvements
that have been made to the front of
viking clothes outside this application
with a new driveway low level wall
secure railings
and new planting a significant
improvement to its current
substandard state the applicant had a
meeting with what the one objective to
the scheme
and clarified the concerns raised the
materiality being clarified as
render and the clearing of vegetation to
the boundary clarified as
outside this application and agreed by
all residents of viking close
the clarifications provided remove the
initial concerns raised
on this information and all supporting
information provided for this
application
it should be considered for approval
there now follows a statement by mr
blankly
which is objecting mr blankly says
viking clothes is a is a key component
of the setting and context of the green
man at minis bay
the three 1960s bungalows are of similar
appearance and proportions
and together with viking lodge and bay
cottage on arthur road
form part of the harmonious edges to the
green and the dip
the kent design guide is an adopted tdc
policy and sets the criteria necessary
for assessing planning applications
the proposed building the building
would be multiple breach of this policy
the building would stand significantly
about one meter taller than its
neighbors on viking close and arthur
road
it would result in overlooking of these
and other properties in minnesota
policy section 2.2.13 states
that in most cases the best infill
solution will involve
following the existing building line and
eaves line
even if contemporary in design the roof
will need to be arranged to ensure that
the height of the ridges are kept in
line with the surroundings
massing of the bungalows on viking
clothes is permeable and discreet
the building would present a prominent
bare solid urban mass
destroying the unassuming presence of
viking clothes
policy section 2.2 states that the scale
and massing of buildings
must require relate well to those of
surrounding areas
and that new building should form a
harmonious composition with surrounding
buildings or landscape features
in local views and vistas the building
is a modernist block design of
brick-faced with a mixture of render and
timber cladding
and with large windows on the upper
floor having nothing in common with any
other building around
the green this would present an
intimidating and uncomfortable contrast
to the surrounding conventional builds
policy section 1.3 states that new
development
should build on local character
respecting the scale
landscape style and detailing of
surrounding areas
it should avoid a wide variety of
building styles or mixture of materials
the green has a unique character formed
by its setting and surroundings of
traditional build
all with pitched tiled roofs the
proposed flat roof building would be out
of character and
alien to the green policy section 2.2.1
states that
there is a strong need for the design of
new buildings to enhance
or at least maintain the predominant
character where areas are subject to
redevelopment
section 2.4.2 states that infill
developments
will almost always be expected to
harmonize with their context
the design and context of the building
would make it a statement building
policy section 2.2.13 states that
new building proposals in established
contexts should avoid
bold strong or iconic buildings
good in-field design is about providing
careful repair and cohesion
rather than making a statement the green
is an important part of the minis bay
character
there is a serious risk that if approved
the building would set a precedent for
more competing
taller statement buildings on its
perimeter such development would destroy
the character of the green
and would be detrimental to the wider
minis bay character
thank you chair uh thank you very much
suki
um when i ask um mr liverson please to
give um
the report thank you
thank you chairman i'll just um present
my screen
okay hopefully you can all see the map
for this one so
the application site is outlined in red
at three
viking close as already outlined the
application would demolish the existing
bungalow
and erect a two-story detached dwelling
so this is viking close here the green
that's already been mentioned
is to the west of the site where you've
got uh canal road
and minis road running parallel to each
other
with arthur road running perpendicular
to the site
so this is an aerial image so
this is the property that we're looking
at today
number three here
so this is the bungalow itself proposed
to be
demolished so number two viking closes
just on the left-hand side here
the property in the background here is
number
uh is number eight dane road so it's a
development that's around the back of a
property on dane road
off the distance and this is the other
view so looking sort of towards the sea
from the green itself
and you can see as mentioned that the
land level is slightly set down for
these uh properties on viking clothes
from the actual green itself
and you can see the the style of these
three bungalows in particular you can
see them number one
has a front door window with a balcony
on you can also see in the background
there are other properties in this part
of birchington
and then this is another part of the
green that goes all the way down the
flank elevation
of number three viking close uh you can
also see to the to the rear here number
167 um minis road
which is a two-story flat roof property
um so just look at some other views from
down here
this is a view looking back towards the
green i appreciate it's a little bit
dark because of the
because the weather on the on the right
hand side here is
the the back of the the application site
so
number three on the right hand side of
the image and the back of of number
eight dane road on the left
then turning back around and looking
towards minis road
you can see a bit more of the back
elevation
of 167 minutes road
on the left and then
looking back in a bit more detail at the
existing bungalow so you can see number
one which is um called saxon lodge
number two
uh viking close and then number three
here
so just going to show you two views um
one from arthur road
looking towards the site and another one
from opposite
um the over the other side of the green
so looking from arthur road to the top
of this image looking down towards the
site
um this
is uh the gap between properties on
arthur road
uh you can see uh the the size of number
eight
uh dane road here that we've been
looking at adjacent which is close by to
the site
and the roof of the existing bungalow
number three
is in this area here so there is going
to be a
some visibility from the proposal from
this road and obviously though you can
see the context with number eight there
then looking across the green
you can see here quite clearly that sort
of slight set down that these bungalows
have um and then you can see again
number eight here
and the way that the the the bungalows
sit adjacent to the green and then those
properties in the background as well
that i've mentioned
um that slightly higher the three-story
properties
uh the front minis road
so this the application site actually
extends and so it includes the front
drive aspect of um the the sort of
property fight
on viking close as you can see there
there it was an existing
garage a single story structure at the
front of the site and you see the
bungalow sat
uh slightly an angle to the other
bungalows along
there to turn to form some end point for
the
four viking close uh this is just a
floor plan
of the current bungalow so it's just it
was two bed uh
bungalow and then the roof plan
so the proposal as mentioned would be to
construct a two-story
flat roof property um it includes a
single-story garage
at the front so this is in the same
location as the existing garage
but obviously extends directly from the
the main bulk of
the property so the design is
as mentioned contemporary it's it's flat
roof in design
with um large glazed openings at first
floor
there is a front balcony that is
proposed
on the property uh it's brickwork
proposed on the ground floor
with two different forms of render on
first floor with some visualizations
later on showing that sort of palette of
materials in a bit more
more detail excuse me so moving around
then this is the the flank elevation
fronting that accessed through the green
space so there's actually green space
adjacent to the site
just showing the two-story extent of the
building and the brick wall proposed
along that boundary
and the rear elevation with two first
floor windows which we'll look at in a
bit more detail
in the coming slides
and then the flank elevation facing
towards number two
viking close so these are the windows
that were mentioned to be obscure glazed
these three windows here and we'll look
at which rooms they serve
when we go through the floor plans
so on to the floor plans on the ground
floor it's
proposing open plan layout and here's
the garage
that i mentioned
and then on the first floor you have the
balcony here at the front
and then on the side you have three
windows proposed to be
obscure glazed or conditioned as such
mainly serving
uh the two sort of bathrooms as well as
a
sort of dressing area and then there are
two windows at the rear both
they both serve the two rear bedrooms so
it's a three bed property
in total and then this is the
the roof plan again just showing the the
way that the
the first floor has been broken up in in
roof forms with two sections of a flat
roof
in the middle of the property and then
another two to wrapping around
and so you can see here about the
relationship with the
neighboring property um if i click
through so you've got the first floor
layout on the block plan so
one of the issues that we've been
looking at is the relationship between
167
at the rear and first floor windows in
office's
opinion the distance is sufficient from
window to window
and windows to private immunity space of
of 26 meters
there is an interrelationship in terms
of overlooking at the moment because
of the first floor windows in number 167
with the rear garden of um of three
viking clothes
but overall in in looking through the
relationships in the area
and looking at this specific
relationship is consider that the the
proposed rear first four windows
wouldn't result in
substantive overlooking uh warrant
refusal of the application
so in terms of the design of the
property this is a section
showing the existing bungalow on the
site
so you can see number two on the left
hand side here viking close
and about eight day road on the right
hand side
so the proposal would result in an
increase in
the bulk at first floor level and an
increase in the ridge height above the
existing ridge height of the bungalow
you can see how the ridge eye there
compares with uh the neighboring
property at number two
like in close and also how it compares
with the scale
of eight dane road as well
it's considered by um officers that
whilst it does increase the height of
the ridge the site in our view can
support an increase in scale of a
dwelling on this site
predominantly that's because of the open
space surrounding it
that does allow for in to not dominate
the area
or appear overly large because of the
spacing around it
and also obviously there is a
relationship with the built form that
surrounds there including
those those buildings that are very much
in the context of the green such as
a dane road next door so it is
considered that the increase in height
wouldn't result in significant harm to
the character and appearance of
the area and it does prove provide a
transition between the the bungalows and
the the full
two-story property a dane road quite
well
in terms of the side section just
showing the relationship with the
property at the rear 167.
so you can see this is the two-story
flat roof building as it is now
and um of the neighbor and on the
left-hand side you've got the existing
bungalow
so you can see the height is comparable
with the flat roof building to the rear
um and you can then see that the
relationship between the windows as
already mentioned
and shown on the first floor plan
uh so the visualizations of the scheme
that i mentioned so these are
our 3d images these are not being
conditioned to be accorded with but
we have requested that there will be a
samples condition placed upon any
permission to ensure that we get
to assess the materials that come in
um what this is proposing is to have
brickwork at the ground floor with then
two types of render
at first floor white render and sand
colored render
to break up the mass of the property
this is a visualization showing that
side the rear elevation
sorry of the applications proposed and
the existing bulk
represented on 167 on the right hand
side
and this is a view just showing front on
the relationship between the neighboring
property
and the proposed development
in terms of the that's um been raised in
the officer report
about um the the previous tree
preservation order
as mentioned um there was a tree
preservation order uh which was
one of a number of trees that were
individually protected within an
order in the mid 90s
there we don't have any records of any
complaints
on file uh that would that show
when the tree that was covered by tpo
around this location here
was actually removed and the report does
look into
the fact that they have what's been
proposed here is
not only a replacement individual
sycamore which is t1 which is here
but also it does include additional
planting in the rear garden
so it is considered that um that there
is obviously a replacement tree
um that was removed before the current
applicant
was the owner of the property and
therefore
overall it's not considered that there
is detriment to the area
at this stage at this point in time from
the proposed landscaping scheme
um and it would obviously improve the
current situation where
there isn't that tree isn't present so
overall
um it is considered the application
would um
respond to certain characteristics of
the area of
we've obviously looked at the photos to
show there are flat roof buildings
um in close proximity to this property
in the area and is considered by offices
that the site can support
the scale of property without appearing
overly dominant or cramped
and congested and therefore the
application is is recommended for
approval
uh thank you very much and uh i know
that the officer's
recommendation is adopted could the vice
chair
please second or second merchant
uh thank you councillor coleman cook
members
do you wish to debate
i have no names coming up on my screen
i've got
hands yes if you don't mind me asking
members if you could just type your name
in and i'll come to you
some of the hands don't always show up
on this screen that well
uh but counselor right okay mr chairman
um i do
find that i won't be supporting this
application um
i'm afraid and i don't agree with your
interpretation that it fits into the
area
it is a very pretty little close it's
overbearing
and belongs in and it's on
i would say it looks fabulous but not in
the little
area that it is at the moment it's
overbearing and out of character
sorry uh thank you announcer right um
councillor auburn
yeah thank you chair i i think the total
opposite to
cow to councillor right uh
yes it's totally an utterly modern built
building but i think it sits in there
the materials to be to be used
are reasonable and good
um i can't see a problem with it
chairman to be honest and i shall be
voting for
it thank you uh thank you councilman did
i see councillor
zesky's hand go up or
not it wasn't me
that doesn't mean thanks george okay um
councillor keane thank you
um i find because of the building in
dane
road being so much larger i don't find
it
overbearing and i would be supporting it
thank you and councillor joe bayford
thank you chair this is very difficult
for me i generally am
supportive of um progress and i
understand
um the change of style in an area
it is to be expected i have to say i do
think it looks very odd there
it does look out of place um
not sure quite which way to go yet but
uh i i i do think it looks very much out
of place
thank you thank you councillor bayford
um
do i have any other speakers
no okay members i will put this
to you for the vote if i may um
and once again i think we know now how
this works
um i will call your name out if you're
for
against or abstaining
so i will start with
uh council common code against
accounts for organ for councillor
bayford
against now councillor curry
for councillor dennis for
councillor ghana for
council of heart
for chair thank you councillor keane
four uh council of pat moore
for councillor paul moore abstain
councillor zesky
abstain councilman right
against uh myself i am
for it um i believe that
is carried i shall see that will become
it is uh thank you james um the motion
has been
carried members thank you
agenda item 4c which is the east cliff
bandstand on wellington crescent
ramsgate
once again i'm going to call on our
legal office suzuki
to read out this public statement please
thank you chair this is a statement from
miss martin
in favor of the application pioneering
places ramsgate is an
ambitious project delivered by turner
contemporary
since 2018 80 local children have been
leading it
they researched their town and
identified the themes of play and
playfulness
caring and modern machines important to
them in relation to ramsgate
these themes formed a brief for artists
leading to the children interviewing and
appointing conrad shawcross
r.a a renowned british artist
exhibiting internationally who already
commands a great interest in his work
the children and shaw cross have been
working on
developing a temporary artwork beacons
the artwork comprises four structures
each a metal tripod
supporting a coloured perforated disk
the materials reference those found in
the surrounding
area of the royal harbour such as steel
in shipbuilding were the colours drawn
from nautical flags east
cliff bandstand was chosen as it
provides the perfect setting
it allows light to permeate through the
perforated sails
so the outlook is never totally obscured
provides a dramatic view
and offers space so viewers can move
freely
whilst interacting with the structures
the artist was very conscious of the
historic setting
rather than creating something that
blends in
he proposes a work which boldly stands
out
whilst simultaneously channeling the
children's
themes however great consideration was
given to the placement of the artworks
in order to have minimal impact on
residents vistas
and the scale of the structures is in
keeping with furniture
in the vicinity the design ensures
no damage to the dance floor and no
impression left
following removal after 12 months
the artwork can be activated by the
viewer
by operating a handle to allow the sails
to gently rotate
but it has also been designed to allow
complete control
in covid 19 times so there is an option
to remove the handle
whether moving or static the artworks
remain
entirely silent the supporting
information displayed in vinyl
signage will invite visitors to engage
more deeply with the artwork
the bandstand is a hidden gem presenting
conditions for great
greater promotion this commission
provides an exceptional opportunity to
create a new artwork
inspired by the children's response to
ramsgate's
multi-layered history increasing
interest in the site and
huge potential to drive tourism to the
town
it may also be useful in terms of a
future bid for leveling up funds
as this is a place making project
which has been led by the creativity of
local children
it will contribute to an increased civic
pride throughout the whole community a
new interest in the area
could lead to regeneration of the site
with increased and varied use
the artwork will be linked with the
series of sculptures being developed
across the southeast
as part of england's creative coast
promoted by
visit kent this summer the artwork
itself is visually
impactful and ever-changing as its title
beacons suggests it will act as a
literal beacon for the site
drawing more to visit enjoy time outside
and connect with ramsgate
its past present and future in a
meaningful
and inspiring way thank you chair
thank you suki uh well presented there
um i'm gonna ask
ian if he could give his report please
thank you chairman i'll just present my
screen again
okay hopefully you can all see uh the
screen
and so this application is uh the listed
building consent application
for the installation of the artwork
that's proposed
on a temporary basis so the only
consideration of this particular
application
is the direct impact on the east cliff
bandstand
as a listed structure because where it's
positioned physically on the hard
standing that forms part of the listed
cartilage now the other application
which is not reserved for public
speaking
um but will be called out later by the
clerk the committee
would be the appropriate application to
consider the impact
on the conservation area any other
issues
that members may have but for this
particular application
it's just consideration of the impact on
the listed building
itself so i'll just go through the
presentation
now so we've got a site outlined in red
so we are on wellington crescent
um in a very prominent part of ramsgate
members i'm sure will be aware that all
the properties on wellington present
are listed buildings and the site does
sit in there
in the conservation area the bandstand
itself
is listed as well as and you can see it
here the
the the designed panels on the actual
um paving itself so just going to look
at some views
of the site so this is a view from
planes of waterloo looking directly to
the bandstand you see some of the
sort of crane from the pleasure on site
behind
and you've got um the street lights here
and moving through
you'd see the um the crescent of
weddings were present in the background
and this is the band stand itself
um so the walls here and the railings
are specifically cited in the
the listing as well
then just looking this is the the
problem itself so you can see the level
change that occurs
here i'm just looking at
the the band stand in the detail
and then the other angle of the band
stand looking the other direction
and then again the drop off sorry it's a
bit blurry on that photo the drop off
between the
the band stand and the surrounding um
land and the actual problem itself
and this is a longer view i appreciate
the
the bandstand is from hidden behind the
sun in this photo on the left hand side
but um you can see quite clearly how the
the crescent
is the dominating factor in terms of um
the the bandstand and how the two space
as two structures sit together
and then this is just another view again
just showing uh the band stand
here from the other side of the road in
front of the wellington christmas
properties
so the proposal as mentioned is for four
structures on tripod stands
they are proposed uh to be cited on
these concrete pads um it's proposing
that
the structures are off steel and have
a large steel pole with circular discs
on them so as mentioned i'll just click
through to the next one which might make
a bit more sense
there are four of these that are
proposed it's already been outlined in
the
public speaking about um the background
behind these discs and indeed the the
funding that's that's come forward for
it
um this is to look to celebrate maritime
heritage of ramsgate
it's been mentioned already that these
discs was
being colored uh they will be able to be
uh
sort of turning around and that will
sort of almost reveal
a a code to relate back to the nautical
flag
theme and colors on the discs themselves
in terms of the
structures itself in terms of size
you're looking at
overall height about eight meters just a
bit more than eight meters
um with a span of the actual discs
themselves of about 3.6 meters and it's
about five meters to the
sort of midpoint of the the discs itself
so they are
they are eight meters in in height
generally
and going through is a visualization
that's been provided of what they're
they're going to look like
in terms of the impact on the listed
building
as the the bandstand it is considered
by officers that there is harm to the
character of the asset
by virtue of placing structures like
this
on the the listed structure itself
and obviously in relation to the listed
stand
however that impact is temporary
this is proposed only for a year and
also there are
quite clear public benefits from the
proposal in officers views
one that's already been mentioned is
obviously the potential for the project
to actually increase the use of the
space
um by providing something that for
people to come and look at
and indeed additional use of the band
stand itself
um it also is about the principles that
are enshrined in
local planned policy to do with uh both
listed buildings and generally to do
with social interaction and inclusivity
and the potential tourism benefits that
would accrue from
having an art installation like this in
this location
and it's therefore considered by
officers that the temporary harm
to the asset in this instance would be
outweighed
by the public benefits during the course
of the installation
in this instance and therefore the
recommendation on this application is is
for approval
uh thank you very much ian uh once again
my movie officers
recommendation is adopted could the vice
chair
please second or second nature
uh thank you very much uh council
coleman cook um
i see that uh council organ
wish to speak yeah thank you chair yeah
i called his applications in
um the reason i called them in was
because
uh residents of wellington crescent had
concerns
uh in relation to looking out upon
upon these art
artifacts and um and the effect that it
might have
on the bandstand
um personally um
i fully support this um
art exhibition whatever you want to call
it and as
uh as mr livingston has said it's it's
there for a year
i think as well um
in ramsgate we've now got a burgeoning
um
artistic bent to want a better words um
and
um which is which is growing on a on
on quite a fast basis so i i think
this is quite important for for ramsgate
to have this and i think it will uh it
will bring
the businesses out to see exactly what
it is because if they can see it from
the beach at which they probably can
uh then then the town can only benefit
from it
from that year for this year so i'm
fully supportive of each year
and i hope that the other members are as
well thank you chair
i think for that council alban council
curry
thank you chair yeah i agree with cancer
album um
i note that tdc conservation officer has
raised no objection
i think there is a community benefit
to this uh installation it's only
temporary
and therefore i'll be supporting the
officer's recommendation
thank you chair uh thank you uh
counselor joe bather
sorry thank you chair um
yeah i i also support this application i
mean i i think
um it will be a benefit to the community
anything that brings some cultural
interest to the area particularly on a
temporary basis so um you know anyone
that doesn't like it
it's not there forever um i think should
be encouraged especially you know
we've been through hard times i think
anything that
that brings tourists in um brings
interest and color to the area
should be um should be supported and
i'll be doing that thank you
thank you thank you councilman for the
council right um
yeah the fact that the children have
been
all everything everything everybody else
has said the fact that the children have
been involved in it
yeah on that basis yes and it's only for
a year
it's fine what i would have suggest i
think it would be better though
and might cause less impact if there
were two
on i to either side of the bandstand
rather than the fall across the front
that would lessen the impact of the
residents
i think on that one council right
i can understand what you're saying
there but obviously this is the
application
once again we are looking at um
and it has been as you well know looked
into
correctly um
if i may um i'm i think it is
a good idea and certainly i know the
area
um with the bandstand um
yes it needs brightening up up there a
little bit my only one concern
would be um the wind
um because it comes right across that
channel but that's
not to say i'm you know
against this application but i don't
know whether ian would like to come back
on council rights um
comment there ian um yeah just
i i think it's it's part of the design
to be sort of equidistant in terms of i
think they're i think about three meters
or 3.3 meters
between each of them so there's a
symmetry to how it's been designed as
part of the artwork
um and again i think from officer's
perspective it is
it's acknowledged that this will be a
visual change uh certainly to the
the listed structure itself but it needs
that that balance of the temporary
nature
of it and the benefit that you accrue
within that temporary period
from from hopefully you know um
enhancement of the asset in its own way
because of the additional use that will
occur
so that's why it's being put forward on
that basis
uh thank you ian okay members i don't
see any
other member wish to comment so i'm
putting this
to you if you're for against or you're
abstaining please let me know
um council common cook
four uh council robin four
councillor bayford four councillor curry
four councillor dennis
councillor ghana four councilman heart
forger councillor keane four
councillor pat moore for council paul
moore
for councillorski
or councilwright
and i am i'm for as well but that is
uh unanimous thank you members
and i think that's something we look
forward to seeing something completely
different
right uh agenda item for e
which is number 51 london road rails
gate
um once again i'm going to ask suki who
i know has been looking forward to this
one
uh to redoubt her statements please
thank you chair uh this is a statement
in favor from mr doug brown who's the
applicant
he says thanks chairman for giving me
the chance to give my point of view
first some quotes county councillor
karen constantine it's wonderful
i absolutely love what you have done it
looks fantastic
councillor brenda rogers i pass your
house regularly
didn't know it was yours and it cheers
up the road without being brash
jackie williams former mayor of ramsgate
and former chair
of tdc planning the changes made
have added color and character to this
property
we do hope that you find in favor as it
gives so much pleasure
other quotes it's a lovely house so
cheerful
and how can someone object to that
and not the solar house two doors down
and we live by the seaside what's
people's problem
they clearly haven't got any style
and we love your house when we walk past
it always makes us smile now my thoughts
i live on a main road to ramsgate
seafront
the west cliff is a stone's throw away
i want to promote the seaside town that
i love
there should be color and vibrancy we
should embrace that
and make it brighter to encourage
visitors
design is very subjective i have a
degree in urban design
paid for by tdc so i do know a bit of
what i am talking about
sometimes it is safer as a planner to
not
take any risks so no one complains
one complaint can be dealt with by
refusing an application
rather than risking upset let the
committee or appeal process
deal with a problem the planner can then
say it is not my fault
consider what you are dealing with the
house is not in the conservation area
and there are a wide variety of building
styles in the area
the solar house two doors down is grey
render
blue windows grey cladding
a grey metal roof and white
upvc conservatory if anything my house
matches it
my house livens up the street in a good
way
please members you are all local unlike
many of your officers
you appreciate the privilege of living
in our seaside
towns let's celebrate that rather than
sticking to the usual suburbia that
comprises so many of our modern
residential estates
also please take note only one objective
and 17 letters of support
including support from my local
councillors
and hundreds of supporting comments on
love ramsgate
facebook page do the good thing and
allow
more happy design in the district
thank you chair thank you very much
spooky um
i call now upon account sir brenda
rogers uh brenda
are you there thank you yes um
thank you chairman and members i know
there is one objection to this
and 22 in support there are numerous
positive comments in support of this
application
on social media sites including facebook
and love ramsgate
which far outweigh any negative remarks
the islamic news had nearly 200 comments
this is not the only house in london
road with painted beach scenes on the
exterior
and it seems a shame that one would be
allowed and one wouldn't
then sorry um
neither of these are unpleasant to look
at and in fact they bring a smile to
people's faces as they pass them
particularly as they're both close to
the sea from
this proposal has been the subject of
consultation
people have been able to see what
they're commenting on and made it clear
that they like it
in light of favorable consultation to
results would officers consider changing
their recommendation surely this will be
a democratic action
achieving what the public wants can i
ask why the
why are the ramsgate heritage and design
format
sorry who are the ramsgate heritage and
design forum
what is their status why have they
commented on this application when they
don't usually comment on anything in
london road
did they volunteer a comment or were
they asked to comment by officers
if they were asked why on this specific
application
and i do go along with mr brown his
house is far superior to the
breeze block gray and blue house which
is totally not in keeping with the
street scene
thank you chairman thank you very much
uh councillor rogers
um once again i'm gonna head over to mr
liverson please to give history
good again thank you
i will just present my screen on this
one
okay so hopefully you can should be
yeah visible now yeah um so the
application is directly
retrospectively clad the front
extensions this front extension was
previously approved
uh by the council it's not proposed to
make the extension any bigger it's
literally the materials
on the extension itself so the site is
on
london road as mentioned it's on the
corner with sun augustine's park here so
i lined in red
so this is a view from sun augustus park
looking towards uh the the front
elevation
effectively of 51 london road
and then this is a view from directly
adjacent
on london road of the extension
so then this is an image taken from this
is from google so it is slightly
raised in terms of the level just so
that members are aware of what
exactly what they're looking at but this
is just to show
the the neighboring properties uh in
terms of the the design
of those properties the materials used
and then this is another view for also
from google images
showing the uh the the neighboring
properties of further up
august in augustus park to show again
the style of properties
and the material palette
and then this is the another view from
google just showing
uh again the extension and the balcony
itself so the extension of the balcony
that
is um is a you know accordance in terms
of the size of it
um with the planning permission but it's
the elements of cladding that have been
added
which require planning consent in this
instance
and these are the elevations that have
been provided
with the application showing the
cladding
so in in consideration by officers
um it's about looking at the impact on
the character appearance of the area
and obviously the as i mentioned the
scale of the extension is considered to
be acceptable
originally it was uh proved to be a
rendered
extension which obviously as we've seen
fit in the palette of materials
in the area and indeed there is cladding
in the vicinity of this
particular site in saint augustine park
and
all the way around that sort of it's a
horseshoe type
of development that has two access
points on london road
there are other examples of white
cladding found
in the area um but it is considered that
the proposed materials do fail to
integrate with both the property
and the character of the area in terms
of the design and the contrasting colors
that have been used
it does and is exacerbated by the
prominent
corner location of the property and on
that basis it has been considered by
officers to be
in congress and discord and in relation
to the existing building
and therefore when applying local plan
policy um about integration with the
area
it is considered to be contrary to
policy
qdo2 and therefore it is it is
recommended for
refusal thank you chair uh thank you ian
um once again i move the officer's
recommendation
is adopted uh vice chair please a second
or second nature thank you council
common cook
um members over to you
um
do i have any members wish to speak
yes can you i don't think they're coming
up on my screen
it's councillor keane baker pouncer
councillor keane yes i'm just looking at
the times as well
please counselor keen um it's just um
something to ask really um can you go
back into the pictures
and just show the picture um at the
front of the house again thank you
yeah sure so let me just
so this is the um view directly from
augustine's park looking directly to the
property
and then this is the view from the
footpath on london road
looking at the property and then the
other images are the
the google images a bit further back so
giving a slightly elevated position in
terms of what you would see so
you'd need to drop down slightly to to
know quite how much you'd see
from this view um but this is the the
main images
to consider of of the property
thank you thank you uh
councillor joel baker thank you chair
this is really hard for me um i don't
find it unattractive either but as our
speaker said design is subjective
um we're looking here at um
planning at fitting in with the with the
area and
i have to say it doesn't really um
i have to think about we have to think
about future
um residents and what one person likes
and what
another likes are two different matters
so i suppose the
what we look for is is a design and
color scheme that that suits most people
and pretty as i think it is i
i do think it wouldn't suit everybody so
um again i'm not
quite sure at this stage to go with this
one thank you chair
thank you council bayford um do i have
any other members
wishing to comment
no okay members
again once again i'm coming to you um
a slightly different uh situation here
obviously this is
um for refusal so um if you
offer for refusal please say uh
um for or if you're against refusal
or you're abstaining i think you know
how it works by now
so once again uh council coleman cook
for council robin
abstain council bayford
abstain murray
abstain council dennis
council dennis are you still with us
epstein councillor ghana
against councillor heart
uh this is a difficult one chair i'm
going to go uh against i think
council mckean again
counselor pat more against
council paul moore for
amsterdam
sorry yeah four accounts are
right for and
i'm going to abstain on this one as well
so i'm coming to
uh james on that please there's a
mixture there
uh we've got a tie on this one chair i'm
afraid four
four and four against
um four four four against
indeed right um
i know there's abstentions as
well um your guidance here i think this
is the first time this has happened to
me
in the last two years um
it has indeed i wonder if people may um
some of the abstentions may change their
mind now they realize that it's
so balanced so perhaps if we did a
recount
every run through i have no problem with
that i mean
um i will say this if i may
two members and obviously we have public
who are listening
um i haven't personally declared an
interest
in this item um i thought i didn't have
to
but i do know of uh the applicant mr
mr brown uh because most of you know
i've been on the
authority for a number of years and i do
remember mr brown
being an employee on here
on the council so i think it's only fair
for him and if i may
i'm going to say the same for councillor
orban
if he don't if he shouts at me i totally
understand why
um but it's not an actual declaration
of interest we you know when you know
somebody
i i'm going to stick to my guns and i'm
sure accounts organ will
um are there any other members wish to
have a rethink is is it worth chair
simply doing a full re-vote yes
rather than individual i'm just thinking
just to start and sort of effectively to
run it again on the basis of
the situation okay you've heard the
situation there members and i hope you
again accept what i've said to you um
because i think it's only fair um but i
will go through
and if you've changed your minds please
obviously you will say so but um
this is down as officers refusal
remember that so if you are against
let's say you your gut you you know how
it works um
so counselor coleman cook for
council organ against now sorry
i'm staying
councillor bayford four
councillor curry four
councillor dennis abstain
council of ghana against
councillor heart against
councillor keane against
councillor pat moore
counselor pat moore
against sorry don't worry push
councillor paul moore for
councillors rizzevsky
or councillor right
for myself i'm abstain
right james
that has been carried
so the officer's recommendation has been
carried members
thank you very much i don't know whether
mr livingston wants to come back on
anything there
i think it's it's it's clear obviously
it's been outlined
i'll see what the what the outcome is
thank you
thank you ian thank you very much
right now members um agenda
item 4f which is the outline
planning permission for land of the west
side of top hill street
in minster once again i'm going to ask
our legal officers
zuki to read out public speaking
statements in favor and objecting to
this application and a statement from
minister parish council
suki please thank you sir yes there are
five statements all together
um i read out first of all the statement
of mr hodgson
who's in favor of the uh in favor on
behalf of the applicant
thank you for the opportunity to address
the committee on behalf of the applicant
as the report states this is an
allocated site in the recently adopted
fanat local plan
under policy ho10 therefore the
principle of housing development
of this site has already been
established the scheme will also provide
30 affordable housing in accordance with
the local plan requirement
as defined in the local plan minster
itself benefits from a range of services
including public houses church village
hall primary school veterinary surgery
takeaways butchers convenience store
library
pharmacy post office and railway station
as well as others
the settlement consequently provides a
range of services to meet the day-to-day
needs of residents
as well as excellent access to services
within larger settlements beyond
this includes the railway connections
and bus services
this application will also see
improvements made to the tottel
street roundabout as well as a new
access to serve the development from
cocktail street in accordance with
policy ho10
the illustrative layout indicates the
design intentions for the scheme
the layout shows scope for significant
areas of formal and informal open space
with a network of streets providing
scope for much variety
and occasions to create key landmark
features and vistas
the scheme also indicates opportunities
for a variety of street types
with adoptable routes reducing down to
smaller more intimate
shared spaces the application site will
consequently provide a suitable amount
of open space
which exceeds the local plan requirement
as explained in the report
whilst submitted in outline
consideration has also been taken of
policy standards
such as relating to parking standards
and open space provision
this approach ensures that the
illustrative layout reflects space
requirements
and the principles identified are
realistic and can result in a high
quality environment
in which future occupiers can live as
part of the scheme there will be
financial contributions made towards
education healthcare highways and
ecology the full list is set
out in the committee report under the
section heads of terms
we also wish to highlight that there are
no objections from technical statutory
consulting
including highways natural england
environmental health
and the environment agency in conclusion
we endorse the officer's recommendation
of approval for this scheme
as it complies with all the relevant
recently adopted local plan policies
and will provide significant benefits in
terms of housing provision
and contributions towards community
facilities we trust members will be able
to approve this scheme
thank you there is now a statement from
miss fairbrass who is objecting
in the past the department of
environment rejected this application
as it was on high quality agricultural
land in an area of special significance
to agriculture
and contrary to the kent structure plan
turtle street is often congested at
present
and as this would result in an excess of
500 people
and at least 400 more cars the current
road structure is inadequate an
emergency
pedestrian and cycle access point is
proposed in green hill gardens
often used as a bypass to the village
this is at the bottom end
where there are three bends in the road
within about a hundred yards
the number of dwellings is out of all
proportion to the development of the
village
existing properties are mostly bungalows
where in sanet would residents work
there is already
high unemployment at present it is
difficult to get an appointment with a
doctor
bus services are poor and there is a
problem of schooling
i strongly object to this proposal and
would like this read out at the meeting
there now follows the statement by mr
mrs portena
objecting we are extremely concerned
that the proposed development will have
a detrimental and
irreversible impact on our quality of
life
the village cannot sustain 214
additional houses
and the whole character of the village
will be threatened
we chose our home because of unspoilt
views and assurances the land would
never be built upon as it is grade one
agricultural land
this site is still regularly used for
agricultural purposes
brownfield sites must be considered at a
time when we need more sustainability
the site is rich in archaeology and home
to protected wildlife
the development would cause us extensive
loss of privacy and be a blight on our
currently
unsp bought views traffic and emissions
are a major concern to us
as there would easily be an increase of
400 cars at a time when the government
aims to reduce emissions
within 200 metres of our house and the
proposed site are two hotels
a service area petrol station
supermarket mcdonald's and costa coffee
we already endure constant traffic
throughout the day which worsens at peak
times
during rush hours exiting our driveway
onto tot hill street
can take 15 to 20 minutes due to the
traffic
exacerbated by vehicles and lorries
exiting laundry road onto cocktail
street
bringing traffic to a complete
standstill emergency services struggle
to get through
we started the school walking bus 21
years ago to reduce cars in the village
we regularly count at least 200 cars
at the beginning and end of every school
day as most parents opt to drive
causing congestion throughout the
village it is a safety hazard crossing
all roads enroute to the school
and a further increase in traffic will
risk the safety of children and adults
minster school will not be able to
expand its capacity sufficiently to deal
with the increase in pupil numbers
people driving into minster already
struggle to park as there is very
limited parking
and the village cannot physically take
more cars
there will be additional strain on our
already overburdened doctor surgery
we have gone from getting an appointment
immediately to having to wait several
weeks
the original proposal for 150 houses
increased to 214 due to the
loss of manston airport as there is no
guarantee the airport will reopen
would it not be prudent to awake await
the outcome for manson
before such major development decisions
are made
anti-social behavior has increased since
the last large housing development in
minster
we are frequently disturbed and have
been threatened by youth
hanging around the bus shelter outside
our house
and suffered a burglary this proposal
put enormous pressure on roads
school doctor surgery the water table
and sewage
drainage systems minster does not have
an adequate
infrastructure to cope and the effect of
the development will be
devastating we are very apprehensive
that after 30 years of living in this
beautiful
rural environment we will no longer feel
comfortable
safe or secure living in minster if this
development
goes ahead it now follows a statement by
mr murray who is objecting
further to my letter of 29th april 2018
in which i raised
seven concerns regarding the above
development i should like to add the
following objections based on the new
documents submitted to that council
clear over the moment of minster in the
census of 2011 minster parish had
3 569 inhabitants
the above application requests 214
dwellings
with an expected occupancy rate of one
to five persons per dwelling
this would equate to approximately 500
to 1 000 additional people living in
minster
at the end of construction this is a 14
to 28
increase in the number of people using
its services foul
water treatment plant school doctor
surgery roads etc
this increase is too large for minster
to cope with and will significantly
damage
life in the village inadequate plan to
widen cocktail road junction with
roundabout
turtle street is the main access road in
and out of minster
from the plans submitted for the new
junction it is clear that they are
inadequate people living in the new
development are likely to use 150 to 400
cars stroke motorbike stroke cycles to
move at peak hours to and from the
development
some will turn left at the proposed new
junction with cocktail street
while others will turn right into
minster village perhaps to take their
children to the village school
this will cause enormous traffic jams in
total street
leading to frustration and accidents the
proposed widened access of cocktail
street at the a299 roundabout
will only allow an extra few cars
etcetera to queue
so will not grant free flow of traffic a
completely new and separate access road
should be built from the northern part
of the development to join the a299
minster's waste water treatment plant is
inadequate
in southern malta's letter of 22nd
november 2018 it states that should the
application receive planning consent
then
construction of the development shall
not commence until details of the
proposed means of foul
and surface water sewage disposal have
been submitted to and approved in
writing by
the local planning authority in
consultation with southern water
although there was some limited
upgrading of the foul water piping close
to the sewerage plant when the last
major development
fth071400
in minster was completed in 2010 this is
not adequate to take the outflow from
the additional 214 dwellings
significant investment is required so
that minster is not subjected to the
previous
regular outflow of raw sewage across the
road junction by st mary's church
and along rochester lane conclusions
i believe planning consent should not be
granted because of clear
over-development of minster a proper
detailed plan for
foul and surface water sewerage disposal
should be agreed
before any further housing development
in minster
for any development at the proposed site
a completely new and separate access
road should be built
from its northern part to join the a299
and finally there is a statement from
minster parish council
minster parish council have opposed the
development on this site since 2014
when the draft local plan was first
published and sent out for consultation
over 1 000 objections were submitted we
made further representation at the
inspection process
it seems that none of our well-founded
arguments have been acknowledged
as we are here today to consider an
outlined planning application
for the development of this land in
short the views of the landowners and
the district council have taken
precedence over those of the local
residents
many issues relating to this development
have been raised since its application
was first submitted
including loss of agricultural land
archaeology
water and sewage systems medical and
welfare services
and highways after numerix numerous
exchanges
with various organizations these have
been addressed
often by the promise of financial
settlements as set
out in the report completed by your
planning officer
yet the overwhelming concerns for those
who live in this area are much simpler
they relate to the huge over development
of this
rural community the loss of landscape
the harm to the countryside
and the loss of the village gap none of
these can be solved by
money the villages in phanet each pride
themselves on their unique
character and sense of community this
has never been more evident than in the
recent periods of lockdown
this parish has seen considerable
development over recent years
especially during the last few years
when there has been no
five-year housing supply this has not
been taken into account
at all when considering the impact on
this area
the addition of a site of 214 houses is
the biggest single development in this
village
and will change its character completely
the community will be overwhelmed
yet the conclusion must be that once
fanuc district council
set upon a plan to build houses in
numbers wholly unjustified by the
evidence
then any planning application related to
this site was
predetermined what is the value of
public consultation
lastly the original consultations set
out to the inclusion in the section 106
agreement
of an area of land to extend minced
cemetery
some small compensation for the
imposition of this
development this section of the site
cannot be built upon therefore
represents
no cost to the landowners or developers
we note
that the terms used in the planning
offices report refer to the
sale of land to minster parish council
i urge the committee to include in the
agreement that this land
is given to the community to ensure that
at least
our residents know that their final
resting place is secure
we note the officers are asking for this
decision to be deferred to them
given the nature of this development and
its significant impact on local
residents
i ask that the final decision remains
with the planning committee
thank you thank you chair thank you very
much suki
um for that reading
um um and uh councillor
reece uh wall council reese pew is there
uh councillor pew
yes hello chair and hello committee uh
good evening and uh
apologies for my lateness in joining the
meeting
um i think a lot of the concerns um
and the points that i'd like to raise i
think have already been raised
by a number of residents in the parish
council so i will just
uh summarize them quite quickly um
for me as one of the ward members i was
quite keen to ensure
that this uh application was brought
before you and and
that's the reason why i called it in uh
mainly because it's such a large
application
and it really does have the potential
well i'm almost certain
that it will completely transform
minster village
beyond recognition um many of my
concerns and i'll be honest they are
quite a few and this goes back to to the
beginning
um is that not only has the applicant
failed to i believe consult widely
enough with the community
um to the best of my recollection i
think the last time that they consulted
with the community i think was in 2019
and as we all know with the kovid 19 and
the pandemic
a lot of things have changed since then
and particularly i think
the type of housing that is need for the
village for the villages particularly
minster
we need houses that have bigger bigger
spaces bigger rooms a lot of people work
from home now so i think that that isn't
reflected
within this application um but also as
well
i'm incredibly concerned um it's it's
referenced with
kcc um as one of the consorties in their
responses
that minster school doesn't have the
capacity to take on
any new uh primary school children that
will grow up in the village and need to
go to a primary school
from this as a result of this
development um but they've estimated
that up to 60 new
primary school pupils will need to be
educated uh within the local area and
even within the kcc report it says that
this will happen at the madison green
primary school
in phase one well i mean we all know
that that hasn't been built yet
and actually that leaves residents in
minster and these potential new
residents
at the mercy of a primary school that
may not actually be built
or built in time and finished in time
for this development
which is always the risk and always the
worry and quite honestly it's
my view that if the local primary school
doesn't have room
and has no way to expand and accommodate
more children
then really any sizable development such
as this shouldn't
should be refused alone on that basis
um also as well and this is particularly
a concern that is raised with me
repeatedly from residents along top hill
street
but also in the top of uh the rest of
the village there's such congestion
as you come onto the main road um
particularly around the roundabout
you know many people uh when they're
when they drive to work in the morning
you know i've got many residents live in
hill house drive uh just
adjacent on the other side of top hill
street to where this kind of access
would be
the new axis would be for this
development i have many residents that
on their way to work rather than as they
exit hill house drive and turn right
and then try and queue to get onto the
roundabout to then
go to work across than it and they turn
left and they go all the way down to
hill street they go out of minster
through moncton road
and they then go through moncton um to
get on to
the a299 uh a249 the
the moncton roundabout to then be able
to get to work
and i think as a resident has said in in
one of their written submissions to the
committee you know
there are people queuing for at least 20
minutes to half an hour
to try and get in and out of the village
particularly at peak times
so you know with the potential for this
to have three 400 more cars
you know potentially coming in and out
of the village at any one time
i uh quite honestly it fills me with
dread and i think it's it's for issues
such as that that
the applicant hasn't really considered
the needs of the local community
um you know this is an applicant that is
a sin and opportunity
now that this land has been allocated in
the local plan and feels that it's their
opportunity to cash in
when quite honestly i think as has been
raised it's grade one
agricultural land and as
a ward member i would urge the planning
committee to seriously consider this
application
and that rather than defer and delicate
i would urge you to refuse permission
today
on this application thank you
uh thank you councillor pugh i now ask
our planned officer which is uh emma
fibins um
nice to see you today emma somewhere
to give her report please
thank you chairman
okay can you can you see the screen okay
yup
okay great okay so this is the
application site
um outlined in red and so on the right
hand side of the screen this is top hill
street
running down from um the top hill um
roundabout
roundabout um below and the site here
this is fairfield road leading into
greenhill gardens
and to the south here is um prospect
road and then um above the site to the
north you can see the a299
so part of the part of the site is in
the same ownership
um but not within the application site
so the area in blue
doesn't fall within the application site
so this is just showing the allocation
so the red line
follows the allocation line for the
housing site other than the
cemetery expansion area so um you can
see this area here
is proposed as being part of the
expansion of the cemetery and causing
the red line
but this falls outside of the housing
allocation site so
this area here is allocated in the
planet local plan under policy ho10 for
250 units um
the policy states that the development
should have
vehicular access onto tot hill street
it should be provided with an emergency
access there should be
highway improvements associated with the
development
and open space should um clearly be
provided within it
and the average density suggested within
the policy is up to
35 dwellings per hectare so this is
the application site in aerial view so
this is the area here the darker
area so this area against the north here
isn't within the application site it's
just this l shape
here and this is tot hill street running
down the center
and a closer view of that again top tier
street running along here
this area here is the cemetery so again
this this area here would be the
cemetery expansion area
and to the north side here you can see
this is the list of buildings this is
the closest
basic building to the site but is above
the cemetery area
and here you can see there um top hill
and service services with a petrol
station
um and uh hotel and mcdonald's
so this is just take it from different
angles against top hill street is
running through the center here so
the vehicle access into the site would
be in approximately
this location and this is just taking it
from the h299
looking back into the site again showing
the
relationship between the site and
existing development in minster
the boundary of the site runs along the
area here where there's an existing
bridle way
and again the boundary of the
development would would run along this
central part
here other than the cemetery expansion
area
so these photos um just show you a bit
more detail of the site so this photo is
taken from
green hill gardens to the south so this
is the location of the proposed
emergency vehicular access into the site
sorry again this is showing it again
here so again the emergency
vehicle access would be in this location
and here is um the application cycle so
you can see it is
currently in agricultural use um the
line of
um vegetation along this boundary here
this is the location of the bridal way
and this would be the
boundary of the site so again just going
into the site you can see
existing development within the green
hill gardens um
these are existing bungalows with quite
um shallow
depth gardens and then this is looking
towards the west of the site so this is
the western boundary
along here and the bridle way and this
is looking to
towards properties in prospect road and
prospect gardens
and then again just another view here
and then this is again looking back
towards uh prospect
and road and now this is looking towards
tots hill street so the cemetery
is on the left um to the right
is fairfield road and you can see this
vegetation on the the current boundary
and then
this is total street so you can see the
properties on the
other side of tottenhill street and
again the vehicle
access onto total street would be
approximately here
so this is in tots hill street looking
towards the application site on the left
so the vehicle access would be
approximately here
the bus stop is on the right hand side
of top tier street and again you can see
existing development
and this is running up towards um the
roundabout towards the north
and this is now taken from the north
from the a by the a299
looking south towards the application
site so this is the existing bridleway
that runs along the western boundary of
the site and again you can see the
existing development
um in in prospect road in the distance
so in terms of this
public life area you can see it's
currently an unmade track but is
used as part of the connection to the
cycle network
and for pedestrian use and equestrian
this again showing the uh the boundary
looking towards the site
on the left here you can see the
cemetery
and this is showing the cycle link so
this is the current cycle link next to
the a299 which would which links onto
the bridleway which runs down into
minster and again you can see the
cemetery area here
and this is now is taken on a slightly
uh raised level
so um so behind me in this photo is the
a299 and there's an embankment so
there's quite a change in ground level
between
um the 1899 and the site so this is
taking a raised level just showing you
the difference in ground level
and then here you can see the 1899 you
can see that there's
um a landscaping buffer before reaching
and this this secondary road that runs
alongside here which also has the
um cycle link and then again you can see
the bridal way here and
in this distance here you can see the
listed um
hotel which is the the closest building
to it so the hotel was there
and the development would be on the far
right of this screen
and this is just again showing so this
is not the application site now this is
further west but just showing again the
relationship between the road and the
site and
the existing vegetation that exists
between them
so the application that's been submitted
is not for the full 250 units it's for
214 units so it falls below the actual
allocation number
um it's in outline form so the
consideration is for the principle of
the development for this number of units
and it's also for the vehicular accesses
into the site so all other
matters are reserved as part of the
application this parameter plan has been
submitted so this would be one of the
approval
um plans and what this plan is showing
is that the green area here would be the
cemetery expansion area
so this has been submitted because the
original policy
allocation the education policy for the
site actually included
um a requirement to expand the cemetery
as the um plan has gone through um
through the inspector it was decided
that there wasn't a need for this
expansion and the inspector removed this
from the policy
so the policy now no longer requires an
expansion of the cemetery
however it's still being shown on the
plan so if the plan
was to be approved it would be approving
the change of use of this land for
cemetery expansion
um use and then that would be available
to
um the parish council but um it's
understood that that'd be
for the parish council to purchase from
the applicant rather than it being a
requirement
that this land is provided to the parish
council
and there's not a requirement for us to
be able to to
demand that through a legal agreement or
for a condition because it's not a
policy requirement
but that has currently been still shown
on that parameter plan
um the aryan pink is the archaeological
exclusion zones
so from work that's taken place prior to
the submission of the application it's
been found that the
site is very um rich in archaeology
and it's shown that there's a roman
trackway that runs through the site so
this long line here is the roman
trackway north of this area there's
evidence
of two small settlements and there's
also
evidence of um brunch bronze age barrows
which are the circular areas
which are basically old burial
grounds um from from the bronze age so
these areas have been found to be
extremely important and not something
that we would want to build over
and therefore they are shown on the plan
as exclusion zones where development
actual
physical development cannot be
constructed over it
the only exception is the vehicular
access the vehicle access comes into the
site here and would
go over that exclusion zone at a single
point
um but that has been accepted by the
archaeological officer
and the area i've shown in yellow is an
area that
restricts the maximum height of
development so
it's showing it as no more than one and
a half stories in height
so um i'll just show you this plan in a
bit more detail
so the reason for this is that the
properties in green hill gardens
are bungalows the gardens are quite
shallow in depth
and therefore it's um being considered
when
when when the applicants can you know
consider the application prior to
submission
that any development exceeding one and a
half stories could have a significant
impact on them and therefore this has
been shown on the plan
as being an area restricted in height to
one and a half stories
which basically would result in um
shadow star bungalows
um therefore with limiting impacts on
those properties
and so this plan has also been submitted
this isn't a plan for approval but it's
just
an addictive plan showing the the amount
of open space across the site
so the plan is showing that in terms of
formal open space
which we would consider to cover um
amenity green space allotment space and
play space
that 0.5 hectares of this is being
provided
this exceeds the 0.53
hectares that's required through um the
policy in the local plan
so this that exceeds the minimum and in
terms of the informal open space which
covers the general landscaping so this
is the area that's lighter green around
the edge of the site
and this area is shown as being 4.12
hectares
and which significantly sees the 0.92
hectares
requirement within the policy so the
reasons for this is has linked to
the fact that there's been the
archaeological exclusion zones that's
limited the amount of
development that can actually fit onto
the site which is what has also led to
the reduction in the unit numbers so
the 214 falling below the 250 is because
you can't actually develop
any of this area above here and this
area here so this
has limited that so it's actually
resulted in quite a low density
development the density if you include
the open space
the density is at um earth
uh 16.5 um
sorry per hectare um but then if you
excluded the open space it would be 30
so it's actually below again the policy
requirements it's quite a low density
development which again is is um
characteristic of a village location
where it's surrounded by agricultural
land so actually quite a low density
development is
is supported here
so this is the initiative master plan
that's been submitted with the scheme so
this plan is not for approval because
the application is not considering
layout um or design um but it's showing
how
um 214 units could fit on the site
without causing um harm
so what the plan is showing is again the
the fact that a
load development is achieved it's shown
that there's a mix of
um terrorist detached and semi-attached
units that could be achieved across the
site
whilst also retaining large areas of
open space around the
site um the unit
sizes reflect the mix that's within
policy sp
22 which is our current need for unit
sizes so
this would be um
addressing local need and therefore that
type of that unit split would be
acceptable but again we're not actually
approving that
at this stage but this is what the
initiative master plan has been based on
um in terms of of impact on neighbours
again there's no
no detail in terms of location so it's
difficult to actually
fully assess any impact on neighborhood
properties at this stage
but in terms of the distance you can see
this area um here would be the area that
would be the one and a half
story high um development and you can
see that they
there is it's possible to get quite a
good distance to the neighboring
properties
in order to avoid any overlooking
there's a distance of
um or the gardens of these properties in
greenhill gardens is 16 to 20 meters
and so with a garden depth beyond that
you'd easily be achieving
at least 21 meters if not more and for
the properties in fairfield
road they have much deeper deeper
gardens of approximately 34 meters so
again there
this would really be no no real impact
on privacy from these properties
and i think one concern was to do with
um
a potential from uh security because of
the fact that there would be properties
towards the rear of these gardens
i think one one condition that we've
requested is to do with looking at
boundary treatment exists along these
boundaries and making sure that the
neighboring properties would be secure
and not have
any any judgmental impact from this
development
um it was mentioned in the planning
statement or submitted that development
could be
going up to three stories in heights and
i think that quite a few objections i
saw where
in relation to this we would be
concerned with any development up to
three story and high in a village
location
that's not considered to be a suitable
scale of development
um so we have suggested a condition that
does
limit any development up to two story in
height up to ease level
so it would allow potentially some
accommodation at roof level but would
limit anything up to two stories to each
level and which will prevent any any
scope for any three-story development on
the site
so it's just more zoomed in a plan
showing the
the relationship with properties so
in terms of highways um as i mentioned
there will be
this access here onto top hill street on
the this point here
and there's an emergency access proposed
at this point here onto green hill
gardens
so this plan here shows the proposed
access onto top hill street
it shows that adequate sight lines can
be achieved
and it's also showing that there would
be an uncontrolled crossing point
located in this area here which would
allow for pedestrians from the
development to
cross the road and access the bus stop
which is located on the this side of the
road
and then in terms of the emergency
access here
this is the plan for this so it showed
that there would be retractable bollards
positioned towards the center of the
access which would allow for emergency
vehicles to access the site
should they require it
in terms of their mitigation from the
development
the assessments that have been carried
out the transport assessments have shown
that
top hill roundabout is at capacity
already and therefore any
additional um traffic from this
development would be causing
harm and therefore mitigation works are
required the mitigation works that
they're
proposing is the widening of the arm to
the roundabout so
this area here is a new lane
leading onto the roundabout and which
would allow for
um any additional cueing that would come
from the development it would allow um
that that to be absorbed by through the
additional um lane
leading onto the roundabout so this work
would be carried out at the expense of
um the applicant and is required as part
of the legal agreement
as well as the condition and the other
issue was to do with the impact on um
i'm sorry this is just showing the
overview of actually the
whitening would be in this location here
so just beyond there
access to the cemetery this area here
would be showing the additional lane
leading onto the roundabout
and then in terms of the other um
junction that's
where concern have been raised it's the
junction is here so spitfire away
it's found that this is also at capacity
at the moment
and so whilst vehicles coming out here
would would spread when um
reaching the roundabout is considered
any additional impact
from um additional movements would
actually be causing harm and therefore
a financial contribution has been
requested in this case it's been um
determined that this should be 166 000
pounds
which will go towards improvements at
the spitfire way junction
as part of the highway strategy
um the other um
aspect is the public right of way so the
bridal way that runs along the western
side of this site as you saw in the
photos earlier
is an unmade track concern has been
raised by
um kcc the public right of ways officer
that any additional
um people using this track which would
probably be significant given the fact
that the development is is basically
leading
next to the track it would cause
problems with that track given the fact
it's an unmade
um track and it would cause damage to it
and this is quite important link given
the fact that the cycle
network um extends onto it and it's a
main footpath link
so as part of the um application it's
been requested that
the re the surfacing of that right away
the full length of the bridal way
takes place as part of the development
so that would be a hard surface to three
meter width
running through from the 89 1899
on to prospect road to the south and
that would then
significantly improve pedestrian links
and cycle links and would
allow enable equestrian movement as well
and so that is also proposed as part of
the legal agreement
and again that's just the photo again
showing you the existing track
so that would be um maybe three meters
wide and hard surface
so in terms of the general development
it's been mentioned about the fact that
the site is agricultural
land and grade one unfortunately quite a
lot of
um agricultural land than it is at that
level um
the site is however allocated for
housing and therefore
the benefits of housing development on
the site and the benefits that
come from that would override the fact
that is
grade one agricultural land the fact it
is um an allocation site
in terms of the impact on on the
surrounding area the site now falls
within
um the urban areas the boundary of
uh minster village has changed to
include this as part of the village
confines
however the site does still fall within
the landscape carriage area
so in terms of views through towards um
bay in the distance
um a landscape assessment has been
submitted obviously it's quite an open
site as you saw from the photos so the
development of the site
will be causing some visual visual
impact as a result of that
however the main views which would be
from um the 82
829 looking south towards the site there
would be a backdrop of existing
development
around the site so in terms of long
views this the harm would actually be
limited because of that um in addition
that um alaska landscape strategy has
been submitted this again is not
a plan for approval because we don't
company have the the layout being
proposed
but this shows what could be achieved on
the site so this is tottenham street
running along to the north
so the 1899 would be and to the left
here the yellow
dots um are the bridal way and it just
shows
what could be achieved with the open
space the fact that there could be
native tree planting along the site um
hedge plants in
there can be um large areas of
i mean this this area here showing the
potential drainage solutions for the
site which will allow for infiltration
into the site
and it shows potential links through on
particular pedestrian links as well so
it showed that there would be um the
ability to create some screening of the
development and some softening of the
development
through the strengthening of these um
these um
these boundary areas
so um the other issue to do for
affordable housing so com
with the applications originally
submitted um viability was
uh raised as a concern with the fact
that with all the off-site highway
mitigation works that were required
and there was concern that affordable
housing in full could not be achieved on
the site and it would suggest that only
12
affordable housing could be achieved um
after a lot of negotiation and an
independent review of the
viability assessment was submitted this
has has now been raised up to the 30
so now meets policy requirement um
that it does allow for 60 of the units
to be affordable rent
rather than historically we would have
asked for 70 but
our strategic housing officer has no
concerns with that so
so 30 would be achieved on site again
we'll have no further details of that at
this stage and that would come in
as part of the reserve matters in terms
of other issues there's no concerns with
biodiversity so no protective species
were identified on the site
in terms of the drainage it would be um
aiming to achieve
infiltration through drainage on the
site and again
we've had no concerns raised by
consultees who are happy at the moment
that would be a good strategy
for the site and that this would just be
dealt with further at the reserve matter
stage once we understand the
layout in terms of financial
contributions you can see in the report
there's a long list of
financial contributions that would be
being proposed 144 000 would be going
towards minster surgery to help to
improve um the surgery and make a
increased capacity to accommodate the
additional um people on the site
in terms of their primary school
contribution i know this was this was
mentioned earlier
currently is suggested that this would
go towards the new manston green primary
school
um unfortunately the minster school at
the moment
doesn't have the capacity to expand
there's no space on the site to expand
um
so it's just not possible for the
contribution to go towards minster
primary school
um in terms of the madison green site
it's still an extent consent the
first phase has been approved and
therefore
we are expecting that that site will
still be developed and the school will
come forward
um and that will be um adequate to serve
pupils from this site alternatively
there's um birchington
and primary school which is um the
probably the second closest or the
current closest school other than
minster to the site
and lots of extension works have taken
place at that school as well so there
will be potentially scope there
i think in the past um kcc have advised
that
by expanding other schools it actually
allows capacity for people outside the
area to actually go to those schools
increasing capacity in minster for
pupils because from what i understand
there are people that
come to the minster school from actually
outside the village
so um by increasing capacity elsewhere
that that would actually still help the
village
so other contributions have been
proposed as a secondary school
contribution
um and then a number of other kcc
contributions
so um overall the the proposal does
comply with policy
it's it falls below the adaptation
number on results in quite a low density
scheme
which is not considered to be
significantly harmful to the surrounding
area given the fact is
there'll be lots of landscaping to help
screen the development
and the whilst there will be um harm
from the
additional vehicles this is mitigated
through
the top hill street roundabout
improvement and the um
mitigation through the off-site
contributions from spitfire junction
and so on balance the the benefits from
this scheme are obviously to outweigh
any harm and therefore is recommended
and
subject to the submission of the legal
agreement securing the contributions and
mitigation works that is recommended for
approval thank you thank you very much
emma
um i move the officer's recommendation
is adopted
uh could the vice chair please second or
second nature
thank you councillor coleman cook um i
have uh speakers
uh councillor hart
thank you chair uh as most of you will
know this is falls in my remit which is
one of my
and one of awards villages in my ward um
i think emma did a very good job of
trying to talk everybody out of actually
agreeing to
to this um development because i think
she
all that the only benefit she put
forward
a bit of cash coming out to go to other
other areas
um if you go to bed so i don't know how
many of you do
it is absolutely hideous to get out of
the place and into the place sometimes
you are queuing forever
and just putting another parking area
for you to get out
and wait to get onto the roundabout is
really just
unbelievable um because otherwise you
just will never get out and even you
just park there it's another 20 minute
wait it doesn't make any difference
i am concerned it will change the whole
village
um and it's not in the right place
um we all know there's got to be
planning we all know there's got to be
more houses built but this
is not the right place to build those
houses the school
as emma agreed doesn't have capacity
the what the where they think they could
put them hasn't been built
hasn't been improved so where are all
these people going to go to school
um and i just think that
it's a not a well thought out plan it's
not in the right place
um there's no you can't try and get 240
odd houses or 250 over 200 houses
in an area where you can't get in and
out of and just to have a little bit
extra
we'll have a little uh post that comes
up and down for emergency vehicles that
can't get there because they're killing
or they can't get out because there's
kiwi
um it's an absolute disgrace and i don't
think that this is a well thought out
plan and i don't
think it at all should be agreed by
planning if he's going to be
uh approved in any way shape or form it
should actually come back to committee
rather than just be agreed by the
planning uh
and that's my opinion sorry thank you uh
thank you thank you council heart
um here and i see you wish to come back
on this
yes sorry i just wanted to come back on
on a couple of points
obviously this is an allocated housing
site so
the consideration about how sustainable
the site is as a housing site has been
determined through the local plan
examination process so that principal
issue has already been resolved and been
um adopted by this council
and it's it's not a matter for a
planning application
uh to redo
the allocation process i think it's just
really really important
to state that up front um
so yeah i just wanted to put that point
across at this stage thank you chair
uh thank you ian and can i come back
chair on that
yes sir kev's heart yes thank you i
understand what ian's saying as i said
we know it's been agreed as an allocated
site i mean
the the issue i have uh as many ward
councillors will have in their own areas
and has been put forth by kcc and it's
been put forth by
mr parish council and emma did a very
good job of saying it's not sustainable
as a site
um is that we agree that that that has
been agreed there's nothing we can do
about that but it will
not take that number of houses if they
want to put a housing
allocation onto that site maybe they
could put 10 or 20
but not over 200 houses because the
infrastructure isn't there
okay there's a station they're not going
to walk the mile and a half down to the
station
they're going to drive which means
they're going to have to come back at
some stage
there's no real transport links at the
top of the road buses etc
there's no place for the uh people to go
to the medical center at the present
time let alone with another 200 plus
houses
there's nowhere for the children to go
to school um
and it's just an unviable product um and
i
i cannot state enough yes it's an agreed
a point
it's an agreed area to put to put houses
on but it won't take that many if you
want to put 50 on there or 20 on that
fight
but not 240 odd i mean it's just not
sustainable
even the drainage isn't sustainable and
they're taking away the expansion of the
cemetery they're doing nothing to
actually enhance sierra at all
and i i just think it's a great shame to
to do this
it's just going to cause absolute um
dread people just won't be able to get
out of the village i mean it's it's just
crazy you can't get out
now let like get in so that's just my
comments sorry
uh thank you counselor i mean i think
i have to say this i mean it's been
mentioned by
the officers you know this is part of
the new local plan
allocated the numbers the houses
um i okay that's being looked at um
and we have we have to take what
officers are
stating to us and i know we have every
right
that's what we're here for tonight to
discuss our thoughts
and whether we agree or not agree but um
i think
you know we've got some plans coming up
one next week um
which can be very big and uh obviously a
lot of debate will take place
but i think we've all got to remember
that if this is in the local plan these
sites are in the local plan
um we have to consider that uh
and i'm not asking you wouldn't dream of
it as i've said
on the odd occasion before to agree or
not agree that is your
decisions but i think if i may it's a
bit of an important point
so and i i have got other speakers but
um i think ian would like to come back
members thank you chad i don't want to
labor the point because i think i
you know i absolutely understand council
hall's position um
as a as a member of the committee um
i think just to reiterate that obviously
the site is allocated for
for up to 250 houses and obviously in
this instance
it's come forward for less because there
are specific reasons
on site why they can't provide 250
houses which the site is allocated
for i did just want to pick up and this
was covered in emma's presentation and
there may be further comments on this uh
the point with regards to
the school and the capacity of the
school because the point that's being
made by kcc
is that there is in terms of a
contribution which every development of
a certain scale is expected to make
towards
the provision of of of new sort of
school places through expansion projects
um that doesn't necessarily mean that
year on year
there are capacity issues at minster
primary school
that would mean that the people in this
the you know the families of this site
would not be able to attend minster
primary school it's to say that the
money from this development
couldn't go to minster primary school
because there is no
projects to expand that school and there
is a
clear difference there that's that's a
different thing from saying that
when these houses are built that there
wouldn't be any space for the children
at that school and as emma's already
outlined
expansion of other schools outside of
minster
creates capacity outside of minster and
indeed
an oversubscription policy of which i
believe minster parish council
used the kcc over subscription policy
would mean that one of those one of
those policies for when the school is
over subscribed
relates to how close you are to the
school itself and obviously therefore
people in minster would be prioritized
thank you chair
uh thank you ian um right i have other
speakers accounts are auburn
yeah thank you chair um
this is an interesting debate and um
i have to say that obviously the local
plan
this scheme was this this land was put
into the local plan
for up to 250 houses so and and the
council
us as councillors have approved that
so this site is to be used for
development
for houses however
whilst that is agreed and uh
and it's part of and gone through a due
process
it is the intricacies of the
development that takes place
which is going to cause the problems
i've got family
in minster and i go down on a regular
basis and i totally agree with council
heart and i totally agree with
with councillor pugh it is it is a bit a
bit of a nightmare even on
even on the um even on a less busy day
it is difficult because of the parking
uh there so you've you've got to weave
your way up
in and out my concerns in listening
to this was one on the highway issues
and two on the school
but i've listened to what the officers
have said
and it's down to kent county council to
ensure
that there are enough places and there
are enough school places
for developments like this to take place
and for the children that
may live on this site to be accommodated
elsewhere
if they can't get into minster
my other my other concern is
is the access into the in and out of the
site
now it would seem to me
to be folly um
for traffic to be able to turn right
out of this development site to go down
into the town
and down into the village they should
turn left
go up and go around around about and
then come back down
um also what concerns me
it as well is that a pedestrian access
is to be put in going across total
street to allow
obviously uh residents on foot
to gain access to the bus stop there
i think that needs to be looked at that
needs to be looked at as to whether
they should be able to get a um a bridge
across
um because that inc that in turn will
will will stop traffic
as i i i whilst
i am willing to support
the um the outlying consent for housing
on the site i do
think that there are issues
coming from that which need to be
further looked into
and determined to ensure
that the that the general life of the
villagers
doesn't get any more detriment to any
more detriment than what it's got at the
present time
in relation to traffic schools and other
things
thank you chairman uh thanks for that uh
council robin
look at that obviously you can see make
sense uh cancer bayford
thank you chair um councillor alban has
actually articulated many of the things
i wanted to say
um i fully understand that the society
is allocated for housing i understand
the number of houses
that it's allocated for there are a lot
of positives i have to say
um that the dwellings are limited to two
stories um
financial contributions the the
percentage of
affordable housing however
um i i fully respect
the effect this will have on the village
and the villagers
and i think for that reason the number
of unanswered questions related to um
to schooling um uh
highways things like i think there are
too many unanswered questions at this
stage
i feel these things need to be firmed up
maybe there needs to be further
consultation i don't know
but i feel that it is a little bit early
at this stage to agree to this
application
in its current form um i don't know if
there is any
way that this this could be further
deferred
in order to to find solutions to these
issues but
i personally feel uncomfortable at this
stage
um in agreeing to something
which which has such a vast effect
on the on the local people and has so
many unanswered questions
thank you uh thank you for that council
rayford um
councillor paul moore yes thank you
chair chair
am i being rather naive here um the
proposal
is to defer this application to the
planning officers is that correct
that's correct right so that's what
we're voting for
um but what we're saying is if we don't
agree with that
then it will come back to this committee
for further discussions
where we can deal with all the points
that have been raised councilman i'm
going to stop you there because i
i can see that council council i've done
it again ian
uh but you you i don't want to put you
through that
uh but i think mr livingston can come
come back on that
okay i think thank you chad so the
application
the recommendation is to defer and
delegate
for approval so the members are making
the decision about whether or not this
application gets approved or not
but it's deferred back specifically for
us to finalize the legal agreement to
secure all of the planning obligations
that are outlined in the heads of terms
in the report
so if um that motion that's been put
before members falls
then it would be for members to propose
an alternative motion of
obviously as normal i would advise on
that if that was
the way it goes thank you thank you in
for that
um if you're quite happy with that
counselor more yes
yes thank you ian thank you chair thank
you um
counselor keen thank you chair um
yeah i fully i mean i'm going to be
repeating a bit what the others have
said so i'll keep it brief i fully
understand the site's already approved
and the numbers and that
um so that goes ahead but my real
concern is about the traffic
i used to work in minster i know it well
and
i can't imagine that what has been shown
to us tonight
is going to be enough to ameliorate the
effects of that number of houses
thank you uh thank you for that
uh council keen i can't see any other
speakers um i can yes
um councillor ghana
you chad i'm a bit of a late entry into
the
the discussion um i won't take a long
time because
a number of councillors have already
outlined concerns
that i share with this application
um one one other concern i
share um i haven't been assured
about the amount of affordable housing
that is going to
end up being provided on this site when
it is finally
when it does finally gain permission
i've heard it's stated that
after an assessment it was thought to be
12
and then following negotiations that was
moved up
up to the um the 30 as it should be
um i would have i just want to make it
clear i would have
grave concerns if not worse
if this came back at any future date
and that 30 was reduced by any any
amount
i mean it needs to stay at 30
thank you i thank you council ghana i
don't know whether
emma wants to just comment on that
uh yeah so the proposal is
is currently for the 30 and it's
proposed that that would be
secured within the legal agreement so um
yes i originally proposed 12 we've gone
back and forth
and we've reviewed it through the
viability assessment and it's been found
that they could actually achieve 30
percent on the site whilst remaining
whilst site remains viable
so that is now to be secured through the
legal agreement so there's no scope for
them to
come back and um and reduce that
at this point um because we are now
proposing
that 30 would be would be achieved on
site and that would be in the legal
agreement
requiring details through the reserve
matters of where that is and
what size those units would be um so yes
that there's no there's no concern there
with that element and can i just comment
on
the other points being raised i think
you've you know mentioned members have
mentioned quite a few unanswered
questions with this in terms of the
highway impacts again i can understand
the concerns that members are raising
with it is
difficult um sometimes getting into the
village but
the proposal for this development is in
the north of the village
so it's probably actually the best
location in terms of
the impact on highways because most
vehicles would come out of this site and
immediately turn left onto the
roundabout i appreciate you saying that
some people may drive down to the
station and
some people may want to drive to the
school but a development in this
location
in my view is is going to be better than
something further south
right in the middle of the the center of
the village because this can people
could come straight out of this
development straight onto the roundabout
and the mitigation works obviously
seeking to improve the roundabout and
widen that so
that highways have raised no objections
to this scheme now so there's
no concerns raised by them following the
submission of all the transport
assessments and additional information
that they've requested
they've asked for lots of additional
information they've asked for the the
crossing point and things like that so
following lots of negotiation back and
forth kcc highways now raise no
objections to the scheme and consider it
to be
acceptable following the securing of
these mitigation works through the legal
agreement and
this financial contribution for the
spitfire junction
so um and in terms of the school i think
we
we did cover this point earlier is again
i appreciate it's difficult
suggesting that the money will go to a
school that doesn't currently exist and
therefore i can see your concern that if
that school isn't built there could be
an issue but
again there you know that from develop
coming forward we
development will provide contributions
to schools and eventually they will come
forward and
there are other schools that can
accommodate children there's the
birchton school
there's as we've said the minister
school would get priority for
any children in this development um so
again i don't feel
in terms of there being unanswered
questions there's nothing more i can see
in terms of information
on those issues so i just wanted to just
thank you very much for that emma um yes
i i can see our
you know concerns here as well but i
think you know you've answered them well
there
that counts for all when you wish to
come back
yes i do chair thank you um
uh as
as much as kent county council highways
may not have an issue
uh they don't believe that as emma has
pointed out that
uh that they have an issue with the
highways but unfortunately
uh we do and uh and we have a
considerable uh issue regarding this
um could i ask
uh mr livingston that
as as far as you know personally i want
to support this at
this application but with reservations
so i would need
surety that
the highway issues can be reviewed and
could be looked at and if not
uh then i think uh would have to go
against this epic it would go against
the motion
uh sorry sorry would be to go against
the recommendation
and for them for this matter to come
back to
members uh for for consideration
instead of in instead of offices
thank you thank you councilwoman um
again i i can see i mean
exactly what you're saying uh um i will
go over to ian um
thank you mayan thank you chair um so
i i supposed to reiterate the points
that emma's made but also
in response to council auburn to your
points there um
i mean the the way that the transport
assessment
works in this instance obviously has
been that there's been
work done looking at trip generation
looking at junction capacity looking at
modeling where traffic will go out of
there
have that new access and as emma
mentioned this has been
an application that's been it's been
with the authority for for over two
years
and all of that has been been dealing
with the negotiation over
multiple factors including concerns from
kcc highways
uh obviously in that time this site has
been allocated and i know i don't want
to bang on about it but
the important point here is about
actually about the sustainability of the
site the site has been assessed and been
agreed by this council as sustainable
but as as emma's also said i can
understand the concerns because
i think people everyone has traveled
down top hill street and knows that it
can get rather busy because of
park cars on the side um the point about
this site
as emma mentions is that it is of the
village sort of expansion sites and the
allocations
that have come forward it has got that
direct route out
and onto the main highway network it
does obviously have
um good pedestrian links to the south
obviously some of which are provided
through this
through the actual site itself to go to
the south that would then go
down to uh the you know the high street
of
minster so it's got pedestrian links on
that way
um and i think to come to the
the key bit about uh kcc highways
whilst i understand members are
concerned because of their own
experience and and what is effectively
though
anecdotal evidence the point here is
that kcc highways that the professional
expertise which they give us
is whether or not there is a severe harm
to the network
if kcc haven't objected and that is on
the basis of quite a significant package
of mitigation works um then
there is no evidence to suggest that the
capacity of the highway network could
not support
this housing development um in terms of
you know if members are not um satisfied
with the information that's been
provided
and then um you know it is something
obviously this is an allocated site
and i you know in our view there are
there aren't grounds to refuse this
application on the impact on the highway
network
um there's no evidence to suggest in
contrary to the kcc highways view
to refuse it on that basis if members
though do not vote for the motion
then we would have to look at what
information
we could get and what input we can get
from highways to provide
any further reassurance about the impact
but as them as outlined this information
the information is clearly outlined in
the report
it's provided all the information about
that and i know members will have looked
at that and will obviously see
online comments from kcc highways as
well going into
a lot of detail about the evidence
that's been provided
thank you uh thank you for that ian um
and yes i have i mean look you're
looking at the report which we
i'm sure we all do um there is a
quite a bit i totally understand
again the concerns on this but um i
appreciate mr livingston have given us
about and i'm saying this obviously and
if members can take this on board you
know they've come back
with their answers and it has taken some
time to do that and i think we do
in some we really have to respect that
um counselor heart you wish to come back
david
sorry mick i believe councillor has
accidentally left the meeting when he's
tried to unmute himself
apologies
oh sorry about that boys and girls um
yeah i unders
i i'm very very sorry i hit the the cuts
off rather than them
don't worry don't worry i understand
with
mr livingston's point of view and i
understand emma's point of view
we're all grown-ups here and we we all
hopefully have been through tottenham
street and we've
all tried to get down there at half past
eight in the morning or trying to get up
and again a half past four order five
you cannot get out of that
street for 20 minutes half an hour
sometimes i've been stuck there for
longer than that once um the issue i
have
is that it's not only about the road
network which is a poorly
actually appalling because where that is
situated
if a car wants to go right into the
estate coming down from the roundabout
people aren't necessarily going to leave
that junction free you can put a yellow
box from it if you have to or whatever
they could be curing up there then they
hit the roundabout and then that causes
chaos further on
if you want to try and get out with
another 240
whatever houses it is over 200 houses
you know
you could have another two 300 cars
trying to just get down that road but
it's not only about the traffic issues
here in
i mean we've had a pandemic apparently
there's going to be a baby boom because
of it
which is going to put even more pressure
on schools more pressures on the road
more pressures on everything else
including the medical services down
there which are very good i understand
um it's not just the road that's the
issue here it's the fact that it's too
many houses in one place
with very limited access so you've got
over 200 houses coming into one
road it's not the fact that they can
come out of another exit or join from
the main
road it's just the whole group of things
that emma described
and described very well but was really
um putting
forward ideas that it wasn't a
sustainable site for that many
properties which i think she did very
well
i think every council councillor should
be grateful to her of in the ward
um that it's just not sustainable and i
think
that realistically to allow um officers
to agree this
um just in principle is not the right
way to go i think it's got to come back
to cabinet
up to committee sorry uh thank you that
uh council heart i mean it's been a very
good debate on this
and listening
some very valid points but once again
um we look at the local plan it was us
that agreed
the local plan um and this site
obviously was allocated for housing
housing as you gather it was allocated
for more houses
uh than the application is you know for
uh and i totally understand your
concerns council heart you know i don't
stop i wouldn't dream of stopping anyone
but um i think
um with the road network again we've got
to go along with what
kcc has said at this stage
um yeah i don't live in minster um but i
i have been there i have trouble now to
margay
um and i totally understand it is
the junction is horrendous at times um
so um i like members to think on that
you know a lot of work has gone on
before this has come to us tonight um
we must think about that uh
council ghana
yeah thanks yeah it was just to confirm
i mean obviously this has got a
if this does pass then it's got to be in
the next three years
an application come back that deals with
the reserve matters
um to be considered and as as far as i'm
aware there's nothing stopping that
being
called into planning committee to be
considered by us
then is there now i mean
you're you're right counselor i mean
listening to all
the views um
about everything on on this application
um
it's not for me to pre-judge but it may
well come back
to committee on some item
about this application we have seen that
before
on numerous occasions over the island
and we'll be open about here and i think
that's
that is the way we should work and i
think we all know that on the committee
um uh but i think looking tonight
obviously i'm going to put this to the
vote in a few minutes
we've we must consider what's in front
of us
um on the agenda tonight
which i'm going to do because i'm going
to have i have no more
speakers and i say it has been a an
excellent debate
um so uh members um
i'm gonna put this uh to you now um
obviously
uh we'll now vote on the officer's
recommendation which is defer
and delegate um you are aware how this
works now if you're for
the motion please say it or against or
if you're abstaining
um i know a counselor pat moore
has had to leave um because i'm saying
there's a ramsgate
town council meeting there tonight so go
for the names um
councillor coleman cook for
councillor alban on balance chair
before being on kcc's head
thank you uh councillor bayford yes
ditto for councillor curry
for dennis
yeah chair although i agree we haven't
got the infrastructure
before thank you uh council ghana
paul councillor heart
against chair thank you councillor keane
against uh councillor paul moore
against chair councillor zesky
right um i'm for it uh i'm
coming over to james
i think that has been it has thank you
members uh
so an excellent debate there that has
been carried
thank you okay we're moving on once
again uh members uh that is uh
concludes the public speaking for this
meeting i will call upon the clerk
which is james um to read out the
remaining planning applications
if a member wishes to reserve the
application will they please
call out and let me know or let james
know over to you james thank you very
much chair
so the remaining two items are agenda
item 4b which is
the application ending 1699 east cliff
bandstand wellington crescent ramsgate
and the other item is 4d which is 13
linden avenue broadstairs
i'd like to discuss that one please do
both of them
thank you council breakford uh but on
the other item
could i just have um
the officer's recommendation there where
are we that was this cliff bandstand
um a proposal that you're happy with
that
and the support approval chair thank you
and a second
chair yeah thank you um
all agreed okay thank you
okay so moving on to the item
which has been reserved which is as i
say is number 13 linden avenue
um i remove that the officer's
recommendation
is adopted because i have uh vice chair
peace second
or second nature thank you um i believe
it's ian it is yeah i'll i'll just go
through
the slides chair just so you can see the
thank you the proposal um
so members will recall this site 13
linden avenue
um for uh the development of
this site here um it's previously come
before members
for the development of two new houses
and alterations
to number 30 linden avenue itself
um so this is 13 lindsen avenue here
the this application is a variation of
condition application so members refused
a previous variation of condition
application which related to changes
to a couple of the dwellings that were
approved
that were fronting the two roads
and this particular variation is to
enlarge
um plot three of the development which
is the the house that you can see in
front of you so it has been
built so i'm just going to show you the
changes that have been made from the
approval
to what's actually now been built and
that they've now retrospectively applied
to regularize so this is the property
itself
the element of interest is on the side
elevation
here um you can see there's a roof light
that's been inserted
into this um that sort of side element
and this is the the dwelling behind
and the site of the house yet to be
built is here
so this is uh the layout
as proposed and the bit that's proposed
is a change to the rear
of number three here so if i click
through to this plan
this is the approved plan for plot three
the section in red is what's changed
so it's it's meant that the the
two-story side element or
sorry single story but with rooms in the
roof um
has basically been extended back to meet
the rear wall
of the property so you can see here on
the ground floor plan
that it's now it's uh i've got a single
linear
rear elevation
and there is some because of the fact
that the pitch has got a bit higher
because it's got deeper
there's the ability that they've put an
ensuite bathroom into that roof
accommodation
and this is the roof plan showing the
the velux window
so the elevations and obviously you've
seen the the actual
uh photos themselves just to show so
this is the element here
which is altered this bit of the back
um and those are the elevations through
um so the materials
that have been put forward obviously
members have seen the photo
but the materials are shown on this
slide here so you've got cream cladding
and you've got some
some bricks as well as well as the
render um the
important thing about this application
is it's just varying that element
all of the provisions on the rest of the
development
it would still be required to be
accorded with
has previously submitted and there's
some more additional details of the
materials that have been submitted for
the overall development
as well so in conclusion
the officer recommendation is for
approval of this variation
uh on the grounds that it doesn't cause
harm to the character appearance of the
area
and whilst it is a a minor material
amendment to the proposal hence needing
a
uh sorry to the approval hence needing
variation of condition
it doesn't result in a a significant
increase in the built form to warrant
refusal and therefore it's recommended
for
approval thank you thank you ian
i'm remove the officer's recommendation
is adopted and that's for approval uh
vice chair police second
or second nurture thank you councillor
coleman cook
um councillor benford
thank you chair um i called this in not
as the
private planning statement says for no
reason but because
um when we discussed this before
um the the last very
the last um application was refused on
the grounds
that i think the reasons recorded were
that it was felt that the permission
granted
was for the maximum balkan scale
acceptable
on that site which is very very cramped
i accept that the the changes are not
huge
i am aware that there is a subset i know
i realize we're not listening to this to
know tonight but there is
another application another variation
coming in
on this same site and we
thought that it it was it was cramped
enough as it was
it shouldn't be made any bigger and then
we're faced suddenly with a
retrospective or part retrospective
application for it to be made bigger
i i don't know how this has happened or
how this can happen but
i'd be interested to hear sorry
uh thank you for that council way
forward council robin
yeah thank you chair i mean just for
council bay for this
this this does happen happens on a quite
regular basis
where people put plans in then
they want to change them and they and
they do that and sometimes work takes
place and then
a retrospective application is put in
um i note on the report that there are
no objections at all from
any any residents um
the what's been done is quite small
it has no impact anywhere on anybody
and should we refuse it
um will the council take enforcement
action
over this to make them take it off i
very much doubt it and
i think certainly uh they will probably
appeal
and uh we would lose on a pill i'm quite
sure that
thank you chair thank you councillor
alban you're talking of an experience
here
um thank you um
yes cancer baby come back
uh yeah i think councilor moore is
before me yes
baker partner uh gone
council bayford you're on like i'll come
back to paul
yeah okay um
i understand that it isn't big
but
there was one application agreed then
the other one came back which was bigger
and we were all adamant i think it was
unanimous that this was
the absolute maximum that we could
accept
and now okay be quite a small change
i just feel that developer is not
um respecting the the decisions of the
committee at all
um i i i understand
councillor alvin's point that if it goes
to appeal we may lose it
so on that for that reason i probably
will go along with it but
i i'm concerned that
this is going to go and go on and on and
on until this this
this site is so cramped and so
packed that it will be completely
unsustainable for
for the for the people who live there
and
and for the neighbours thank you thanks
for that
uh council bayford uh and understand i
mean i totally understand what
councillor
orban has said there i mean they've done
it without permission
we have seen this before but on this
occasion
um it is a smaller
item but i do understand
people should do things without planning
permission uh um
sorry counselor more you came up at the
same time so
thank you chair um i i fully understand
what council bayford is saying
um you know why do we presume that
um these people don't understand
planning regulations
and what has been passed when it's been
put before us in the first instance
and we've stipulated a b and c
yet they go and do g f and i um
i don't think it's right but i also i
believe
what council auburn has said is that
they've chanced their arm they've done
it
they've put their retrospective in it is
minuscule
it doesn't make a great bearing on the
matter but they will get away with it
and that's my issue that i have that
someone has done something to try and
get away with something again
and that we don't have any way of
penalizing these people
when they do this and i believe he will
get away with it if we go to appeal we
would lose it
but i i did believe that council bayford
said
there are other um amendments coming
forward for this development as well
and on that instance i would say well
then we really need to look at that
uh finitely and and make a point
you know don't i'm not saying we
penalize them but we need to make sure
that we are
watching these people and that we do
enforce when we have a chance
i don't think we'll have a particularly
good chance enforcing this one so
it will probably get through uh the net
um but again it brings some highlights
the issues that we have
that when these things are reported to
enforcement we don't have the
manpower or the teamwork there to
actually carry
out the enforcement and produce it in a
in a
a steady time frame and there are still
there are still
things that we've been issued previously
on other applications
that haven't been dealt with and don't
seem to be dealt with and we're not
getting the feedback
so it does worry and concern me um but i
i do believe on both parts
it will get through and uh councillor
bayfield and council gonna
have mentioned everything i was gonna
bring up so thank you now thank you for
that council more um
councillor hart thank you chair
i've just got a couple of comments i
totally agree with jordan
totally agree with paul to be honest
with you um this has been going
on and on and on and i think people
people who do this are as paul voted
rightly but chanting their arm and i
think it's got to be
stopped at some stage and i would like
to see
if ian can answer the question for us
please um
if there are more retrospective planning
um coming on to this site can they not
all be heard at once and dealt with in
one issue rather than
uh bit parts that becomes a bigger issue
rather than just
one infringement here one infringement
there and one infringement on the third
property
so it's just one big issue rather than
three individuals
because i think then we have more
control over what is going on
and i think we can have a better say in
what is going on
and deal with it in one big swoop thank
you
um i know well i would say that council
i think what you've said there in
principle if that could happen
um i think you're right in the way
things work
it it doesn't work that way does it um
these things happen at different times
and so forth
this is again this is my view and i'm
not
i'm certainly not having to go at you
for saying that because i do understand
again
um but we've seen it with
over the years where people it's you
know
they're taking us for a little bit of a
ride
um on occasions it does happen but do
you understand now in
and i will come to cancer although
before he falls asleep there
um yes thank you chair um
so the process allows
under national legislation for someone
to apply
for incremental changes to
a planning application that's granted
permission
um but there is specific provision
within the mppf
specifically cited uh that changes
shouldn't
uh i'm not gonna use the exact words but
effectively it shouldn't degrade the
quality of the scheme
and there is a specific paragraph which
we have cited in reasons for refusal
when someone has come back into vary
conditions
and they are making the development
worse from what's been granted
commission
um the issue with this scheme um
is that on the basis of the the level of
change that's being proposed in this
instance it is considered to be
acceptable
and i think um i think that's that's
obviously been put forward in the report
future applications we can't require
them to all come forward as one
but we do have to consider
the extent of the changes that have
already been made as well as the
decision
that the planning committee made overall
about the site and that is taken into
account
and so the next application was
considered on its own merits
will be informed by the fact that
potentially if this application gets
approved we've approved the expansion
of this property and therefore that mass
is there and therefore any further
alterations to other
other dwellings to make them larger if
that's the proposal or
change the proposal has to be considered
in that context
and there is always a point which
officers
would would draw and indeed members will
as well
which is that that the changes have gone
so far and they can't go any further
and that is something that is is
determined when looking at
impartial character area as well as
obviously impacts on living conditions
in these sorts of instances
but in this specific application uh it
is considered that the changes are very
minor and the sub
and the site specifically can support it
i agree it's absolutely regrettable
frankly that this site has come forward
in this instance and the fact that it's
been built
it shouldn't come forward in that way
but the recommendation is for approval
thank you chair
thanks for that ian um council auburn
just before you
i bring you in i know you've moved but i
didn't think you had
electricity until a couple of moments
ago where you've moved to so
um you wish to speak yeah i've
stopped being a troubler diet now i'm
back into the land of the living
yeah i i think what's important for
members chair is that
you know mr livingston's put it in far
more eloquently than i can ever put it
but at the end of the day you've got to
deal with what's in front of you
and that is a very minor of a very minor
alteration
to this building and it also members
must
uh must take on on board that it's not a
criminal offence to build something
without planning consent
yeah and if you want that
i mean i know loads of loads of councils
have tried to get
various governments throughout the years
to change the legislation to ensure that
should you build something without
consent then you can get prosecuted
but the governments won't do that they
won't do that
so you know you can't whilst it's
annoying
of course it's annoying but then you've
got a look at what they've done and then
decide well okay if they are coming in
the first place
would we have approved it probably and
for me the answer is yes they have a
the plot they haven't gone outside the
the plot in itself
all they've done is lined it up so you
know i
i just think um it's not much to write
i'm about to be quite honest yeah
no thank you that uh i think um
you know all of us who really take
interest and i can see
we do you we see places all the time but
not all the time but
um over the years again it's happened
and um
we have to accept things so um right
counselor right well thank you mr
chairman um
following on from the retrospective
thing
that we know that people do change their
plans that's fine
but i think that i've said this once
before
they know the rules before they do their
minor change they should come
back to the planning department and
tell them what they're going to do when
they do
do it and then apply retrospectively i
think it's actually an insult to the to
the planning committees
because they know we can't do anything
and i think it's about time
we stood up to that i think
that counts right i do do agree but it
as it's been touched on
we we are aware that it does happen
and um to enforce
is a difficult thing um count some more
you wish to come back
yes sorry check councilman's quite right
you know people can build
they take the gambit we do have
legislation
for building consent that's why it's
there um
you can't be naive to say i didn't know
i don't think this is the instance on
this one i think what they've done is
they've looked at the footprint and they
thought if they extend it out that
little bit it gives them a little bit
more space
so they've done it in hindsight and then
applied for retrospective
uh in hindsight if they'd come to us
with that
and and gone to planning i'm pretty sure
planning as i have done now
said it's so incremental that they would
have approved it anyway
and therefore it would have been above
uh
you know question it's just the fact
that they've done it and then come to us
afterwards um yes there is no way of
finding people
yes it does it is frustrating when this
happens but i just think it would be
nice that if it was set in stone
that people had to come back and do it
properly
if no one would get their back up i mean
it does get people's backs up when you
said
this is the maximum and then they do
something else um
it would be all right if they came back
with the drawings and said yes
here it is then we approved it then they
did it excuse me
um but they haven't that that's the bit
that nickels people i think
so um i'm for it because of what it is
and where it is
um it just annoys me that it's been done
and we're getting after the matter after
after the horse has bolted as they say
thank you
i totally understand all the comments
there and i've just spotted um
counselor alban comment on screen here i
won't even go with it
okay um
members i'm going to put this to you
which is um recommendation of the
officers
to approve um again
by now as i keep saying you know how we
it works uh if you're for
against or you're abstaining please tell
me um
councillor coleman cook for council
alban
for councillor bayford i love stone
chair thank you
councillor curry for councillor dennis
for councillor ghana paul
councillor hart unfortunately chair i
will go
for four understand uh councillor keane
four council paul moore
fortune uh councillorski has left us
a councillor right i'm staying
myself i'm four but i do understand what
members have said
tonight uh members
that is it that has been carried by the
way thank you james
members that concludes tonight's
planning
two minutes past eight um